okay great uh our second talk uh for
this afternoon is by uh marsh
bodhihara i'm sorry about that
uh from uh uh irvine who'll be talking
to us about short metrics concentrations
okay so
yeah i feel so lucky to be here because
yesterday when i booked after i booked
the taxi the taxi didn't come
i ended up walking to the airport for
three miles
and yeah just
took the flight just in time so i feel
so lucky to be here today
yeah i have to carry my luggage to my
airport for three miles by walking
okay
all right so
yeah today i'm going to talk about some
sharp versions of matrix concentration
inequalities
okay so the motivation and
start with this very general problem and
suppose we're given a random matrix x
and how large in general is the expected
spectral norm
so there's some well-known result about
this
uh there's a very classical result
um matrix kitchen equality
so
if x is a
matrix for all the entries that joins
the gaussian and centered
in that case there is a pretty sharp
estimate
up to a factor of square root of d so
expanded below by square root of the
norm of e x square
bounded above by
the square root of d of uh times the
square root
e x squared so the square log d factor
is uh sharp
um
and then the small general one uh if you
can write the
random matrix is a sum of
random matrixes
and they don't have to be i be just
independent
and centered there's also a
sharp estimate by sharp i mean just
sharp up to a
factor of log b because if you replace
the left hand side by
e of norm x square and the square root
the left hand side will be at least the
right hand side if you remove all the
logarithms so these two are both of them
pretty sharp up to a log factor
now today's talk is a bit off topic but
pretty much related
no i'm i know they should be useful in
this learning theory
um
the rename so the remaining
question in the literature
is um to remove these um
log factor so that's the hard part how
to remove the factor that's the head
question remaining
and itself
okay so first of all why is the love
factor necessary in the general case
well
it's not needed actually in many cases
for instance
um
if it is like gue or goe all the entries
are iid standard normal
in that case um
we don't need the log factor because dx
square is identity
and
norm of x is approximately two
so in that case the log factor is not
needed
um but there's also a case this is a
very special case a diagonal matrix in
that case the log factor is needed
because if you take the norm of x it's
just the
largest value of the diagonal in
absolute value
and
from that one
there is a square log d factor
so in this very special case
the log factor is needed in that case
it's not neither so these two are the
um two extremes okay
all right so
actually in most cases it's not needed
so what's the big difference between
these two okay
both are gaussian matrixes
well the first one is very
non-commutative
in the sense that if we take another
copy of x let's call that y let's say y
is an independent copy of x
x and y are not commuting almost surely
in the first case
in the second case if we take an
independence copy of x call that y x and
y always commute so
from that point of view the first one is
very non-commuting
[Music]
and the second one is commuting
so
this suggests that if there is enough
non-commutativity
then the log factor could be removed
okay so from this point of view
okay
all right
um now of course
because everything here is quantitative
when it comes to estimation of the
spectral norm of the matrix
so how do we quantify non-commutativity
okay
so
trop made the attempt to quantify
non-commutativity he introduced this
quantity so if we are given a gaussian
matrix x with i mean matrix which joins
the gaussian entries not necessarily id
just joins the option
uh so if we take an independence copy of
x
then we take x y x y and then insert the
unitaries in between take the
expectation and take the norm take
supremum overall the
unitary okay this is some kind of
[Music]
some way to quantify
uh
non-commutativity so that's what trump
proposed and he did prove something we
can improve the square log d factor
reduce the square root of the factor
to log d to the power one over four
yes um okay so first of all uh this one
is always less than equal to this
uh but if they commute if x and y
commute then this will be equal to this
so if this one is much smaller than this
then it means they're very
non-commutative
okay so let's say in the con so first of
all this second order term
is always less than equal to this term
if you don't look at the log factor this
w x is always less than this
but in the case when they commute these
two will be the same so if they commute
then it is a square log b factor here
but if they don't commute then this will
be much smaller than this and this you
can neglect this term if they're very
not competitive
so
well actually the
the way to estimate on commutativity is
wx divided by this if it is equal to one
then they commute
uh if it is much less than one then that
means they're very noncomputing
kind of like that
so that's the way to quantify
non-competitivity
so for example if x and y commutes then
take all these unitaries to the identity
you have x y x y then becomes e x
squared times d y squared the norm of
that
and that's like the norm of
e x square and then you would get w x
equal to this if they if x and y commute
okay
um
all right so yeah the idea is just to
reduce the square log d
to this one but with the cost of adding
a second order term that measures
non-conductivity and this second order
term is going to be small
if
uh
if it is very noncommuting this one will
be much less than this if
it is very non-commutative
okay so that's what from proof
um
okay so of course the two obvious
things not very good first
the square lock defect is net completely
removed it's only reduced to log b to
power one fourth
second thing is this one is very hard to
compute in
general uh even for a very simple cases
like u or g of e
it takes maybe half the page to compute
for general matrixes it might not even
be possible to compute w x
okay anyway so try to make the first
attempt in this direction
i just
uh
try to remove the square lofty in the
first factor and the add a second order
term the nature is not going to do the t
all right so we're going to use another
approach
what's wrong with just using
what's wrong with just using the
standard
you know commute data right that's how
you usually
in this context it doesn't work
you know x y minus y x type of thing
no commutator
or computator is not a good estimate um
because
okay it's the other way around
uh we want a quantity
that is
big
if they commute and small if they don't
commute commutator is the other way
commutator is big
if
they don't commute and small if they
commute is the other way
i i guess maybe another way it's asking
is can you relate the
communicator to wx i mean if you can
if the commentator
is small can you say the wx will be
large and vice versa so we're just
trying to get a sense of i mean i think
some of us maybe are not familiar with
this
measure wx or trying to get an intuitive
sense right stay marker
oh and the board okay
[Music]
okay
so let's see
yeah
so first of all always
um
wx is less than equal to
x squared to the power
this
okay
second
if x and y
commute
the n
um
w x is equal to
this
uh the reason is
um
just very short proof
because wx
will be at least
norm of um
x y x y
the power one fourth
okay
and then this will be
equal to
because they commute so and they're
independent so you have e x square e y
square
norm to the power one fourth
okay they're the same y is just an
independent copy of x
so this is just
this thing square
because this is messing with this and if
they commute then this they're greater
than this okay so what does that mean by
contrapositive
if this is much less than this then
they're very non-commuting
and so
if wx is much less than this one they're
very non-commuting if it's very
non-commuting then
maybe the square log d factor can be
removed so this is much less than this
so this would disappear and then at
least we can reduce the square log d to
this one
that's for drop proof
if they're very noncommuting then we can
remove the factor let me ask a slightly
different question which is really
so what prevents me from having q1 to
q15
and then just writing a long sequence of
x y's x y's 16 times and then uh i have
a power to 116 that still work if i
replace this um
okay first of course there's the issue
of computability of course we want a
quantity that is as simple as possible
so
this one is already considered too
complicated if you replace that by you
know 100 100 of these might be still
true but we want a quantity that is as
easy to compute as possible
all right
okay so
why is this very hard to compute because
this do four things x y x y
what we are going to do is just
just one actually two two variance of x
so we're going to use this quantity to
compute to measure
non-commutativity
actually
so if you have a gaussian vector
um
if you have a d by d random matrix x you
can treat that random matrix as a
gaussian vector
a random matrix you can treat a matrix
as a vector
okay and then you can look at the
covariance matrix and that's a d squared
by b squared covariance matrix and they
just take the spectral norm okay
sounds
not possible right because when you
treat some matrix as a vector
you are destroying the matrix structure
if you destroy the matrix structure how
do you measure non-competitivity
well it could if we compare the ads to
this thing
uh that's the reason
so here's the reasoning
first you can always write the gaussian
matrix x as something like this say for
the entries
jointly gaussian you can write x as a
linear combination like this an akr
deterministic
gk i d standard gaussian
in the case of commutativity if
everything commutes
okay
then
they can be simultaneously diagonalized
by simultaneously diagonalized i mean
with respect to a single orthonormal
basis
all of them become a diagonal matrix if
all the ak are diagonal with respect to
of the normal basis that x can be
written
this way as a diagonal matrix okay
all right so what can we see about
the v of x what's the covariance
so if you look at this matrix treat this
matrix as a vector
most of the entries are zero so
obviously there will be a bunch of zeros
variance never mind these zeros
just look at this diagonal
the covariance
what's the covariance matrix going to
look like
well you will see x one one
[Music]
i mean the covariance matrix of this is
really just the covariance of the
diagonal
so if you look at the covariance matrix
you will see that
you know this x
x 1 1 x 2 2
here
x 2 2 square
[Music]
expectation expectation
dot this expectation of x d d squared
okay and then okay never mind the other
entries
most important thing is that
the norm of the covariance matrix is at
least
the
absolute value but not absolutely
negative anyways the largest diagonal
entry of the
covariance matrix if you look at the
covariance matrix of x that's what it is
plus a bunch of zeros okay by just zeros
and that's what the covariance matrix is
so the
norm of the covariance matrix is at
least the largest one of this diagonal
so it's at least the max of the
square root of these well they have zero
expectations so just the variance
okay
the standard deviation of x i
okay on the other hand
um
if x is equal to this what is e x square
e x square is just the square of all
these and then you take expectation
and that's exactly equal to this one
okay
so if they commute everything commute
then vx is at least this one
what
is okay
and then um
so if they commute then this is true
that means by contrapositive if v x is
much less than this
then they're very noncommuting okay
if they're very non-commuting as crops
suggest
then we can remove the square log b
factor
and that's indeed the case um we can
remove the square log b factor
completely okay crop only removes
partially reduce the square root of this
will not be power one fourth we can
remove that completely
but with another
quantity that measures non-commutativity
which is this one but this one is much
easier to compute
because for traps quantities x y x y x y
x y is four things
covariance is just you know just x and x
just two things much easier to compute
this one
but this is only the gaussian case and
then in the general case we also have a
sharp version
yeah this is the last night of this talk
and i should also mention that this is
john's work with um
sir bandera and ramon
yeah that's it
you had it on the previous side you can
remind us
for if they commute what's the
covariance effects there what does that
evaluate to
in the commutative case
the second term in the communitive case
would be uh for the commutative case
so in non-communication
non-commutative case this will be much
smaller than that but
well here's the reasoning
if it is much smaller than the first
term then they are very noncomputed okay
so for example
if you have a
matrix where all the d squared entries
are iid gaussian
the first one is root d the second one
is just one because if all the entries
are id gaussian
treat that as a random vector that means
a vector
with id gaussian entries then what's the
covariance it's just identity so this is
one and then that will be root b thank
you i see thank you
the questions
can you relate the singular actually
stop your eggs somewhere
[Music]
like wait where this one is
your new the covariance of x okay
here
you also mentioned this w x is it knows
the square root
of
geometric average of these two
i said do you have a lower bound that
was involved
no x no no lower bound okay
[Music]
can you say
thanks can you say anything about the
sharpness because it doesn't look sharp
in the commutative play side
yeah there's a lookshop in the computer
this case
[Music]
i think
a correct sound should be
squarely lofty but that's
so you don't know it's like you you
can't find an example where it's like
this is the dependence on this uh
quantity
on this quantity
no i think this three over two is not
the right factor it should be a square
log d so so you you believe this is the
correct way to measure non-commutativity
uh
the correctness
uh
okay i mean
it's a computable way
to
you also mentioned one result is the
eraser
oh i never mind
okay if we try to
prove something like this
the x
squared plus log d to the power of
beta and then let's say you want
something like sigma star sigma star
x
well obviously a good
way to measure non-combustivity of
course
we would want
this to be equal to
this right because especially for the
neuron i mean if you tense they're up
the x they should be the same
it's also good
you know if
it also satisfies some kind of
triangle inequality
[Music]
all
right
but then um it's it will also be good if
in the
uh
gaussian case
um
gue
uh
yes then you go to this
depending what's the scaling of gui
whatever it is
square
most condition i forgot um
we actually proved that such an
inequality
that would be good right it's impossible
it's impossible so there's actually no
quantity
that can measure non-permittivity and
satisfy something like this it's we
prove that it's impossible
so what's impossible the equality is
impossible
yeah there
so whenever you have such a quantity
sigma star star star design these
properties
we can always construct a random matrix
that would break this one for some
better or for any better uh yeah any
better
as i think it's one more condition i've
yeah i forgot which
is this one more uh i forgot what's that
four four conditions
for reasonable conditions yeah for any
of it yes
thanks
one last question
so your three over two really comes
because you use young selling quality
yeah originally we got three over four
um even three over four is not sharp and
then we use yeah young senior quality
but is that really because
in the uh you're doing any integration
by parts to get an extra p or is
[Music]
uh i think it's
got in one of the step i think in the
point of the step i use the gaussian
covariance identity and then that one
will make the log factor not sharp
that's one thing
the other one is that
here we gain a geometric average because
we use crops parameter in the proof and
then here we get a geometric average
once we have geometric average and apply
young's inequality there's also
something that contributes
to the sharpness of the log factor
okay let's uh thanks much again
[Applause]
that's it for talks for today but
there's a reception outside